and for the rangers it'll be jordan
lyles tonight this will be his 17th
start
whether you wanted to bat him bottom of
the order at the top of the order
loriano on the move line shot to joey
gallow he's going to throw back to first
and
gloriano is out
code irwin has been one of the better
pitchers his records just sixth and
seventh he's around the plate he throws
a lot of strikes
kenner first pitch pops it up down the
right field line tough play and kemp's
gonna get there and he goes
reach his back and he makes the catch in
foul territory
tony kemp was too fast on that play
[Applause]
he got there and then he kind of slowed
down and he realized even though he had
slowed down he had overrun it just a
little bit
good pitch fastball inside corner strike
three call
chapman right-handed hitter he's batting
230 but has 11 home runs 42
rbi
baseball stadiums right next to each
other
chapman opens up the second inning with
a base hit
a little flare and it's gonna work
chapman's gonna try for third gala will
just flip it into second and the a's
have first and third and one out in 186
nine home runs for him this season
and there's the first pitch breaking
ball lined to the right side caught by
embanks he'll step on the bag and the
inning is over another line drive double
play for the rangers
and so we're all pulling for you can't
wait to see it back at the ballpark
bonnie and perhaps eli white with a gift
for bonnie
yeah foul oh fair
that chapman called it foul
is the one that matters and he calls it
fair so it is a home run
eli white i don't think he saw the ball
did you see his call
it was a very
lackadaisical home run call which leads
me to believe
i don't know whether it was fair or foul
but bruce is calling for some help
because i don't think he ever saw it and
bob melvin is out there right now don
lockamatsu unfortunately is smiling i
don't think it's in a good way i think
he's telling eli white that this at-bat
may continue we will see as the umpires
get together there's 14 fastball inside
eli white did a nice job what do you
think tom
ah let's see
baba
get you inside
that was a hanger it's line to center
garcia dives can't get it but is able to
keep it in front of him
[Applause]
i mean that's
you you guys that's the debbie downer
question
fairball into the right field corner
alves anders digging for third gallow
gets to it gets it back in and elvis is
going to hold up at third olson sliding
into second with a double and the a's
are in business here in the top of the
fourth
slowly hit toward third culverson is
going to go to first to get the out
there run comes in to score
i thought culverson was going to go home
hear the crack of the bat
see what kind of jump
oh yeah usable
and it's a force out as well
which
certainly helps the defense i was
dead set that he was going to throw home
and he didn't even look that did not
look around that 70 or 80 pitch mark
there's a fastball swung on they missed
and so jordan lyles does a nice job of
getting himself out of trouble just one
run allowed for the veteran right-hander
irving's got it he spins fires a strike
to second back to first and that's a
double play one four three on the double
play and you cannot ask for anything
better than that it was
stutter step to make sure tony kemp got
to the bag
watch
colt riven right here right there little
stutter staff got on top of the mound
[Applause]
joint gonna miss he threw it by gallow
so cole irvin
a couple of hit batters but nothing else
for the rangers so we're on inning
number five one nothing the eas lead
3-2 pitch here is driven into center
field laureano on the move he slides and
he makes the catch
nice play by ramon laureano coming in to
his left to take a base hit away from
jonah heim here in the bottom of the
fifth inning
and he got a 92 mile an hour fastball
another three up three down inning for
cole irvin
chapman one for two
taking a little time getting into the
box here
that's a base hit for matt chapman he's
two for three
chapman with a big turn and he's going
to try for two the throw to second base
is in time they called him out
happy but he got his foot in yeah
they're gonna take a look at it it's a
double for matt chapman a good hustle
double yeah
it is his 11th
double of the season
that's a base hit right center field and
these are going to get a second run
kevin a hustle double lowry comes
through two nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
and this one is lined into the gap in
right field it'll get down eli wyatt
around second he will head to third
elvis andrews cuts the throw off and the
rangers with back-to-back hits now have
runners at first and third and nobody
out that brings up andy ivanez now for
the rangers
and 1-0 and this one is lined up the
middle base hit eli white will score
easily culverson holds up at third
he took a big turn but with nobody out
taking no chances rangers got their
first run
and now they trail by a score of two to
one
there's the first pitch from romo and it
is lined into center field and that'll
be a base hit culverson scores here
comes kind of for left he'll score
without a throw and the rangers take the
lead three to two
adoles garcia coming up big in the
clutch once again in a ranger uniform
spencer patton is one strike away from
striking out the side here in the eighth
inning with a one-run lead necessarily
here's the 2-2 pitch and there's a
fastball right on the corner at 94 miles
an hour and there is that peak from
spencer patton he looked up to c-94
it'll be the rangers closer ian kennedy
taking over and trying to close things
out here in the night
and here's a swing and a miss by
piscotti kennedy going to the change and
the a's are down to their final count
there's the one pitch and this one is
lifted
in the deep center field but garcia is
there he makes the play
and the ball game is over a very nice
3-2 win for the rangers